why is it victim blaming to say where
you're at in life is your own fault it's
based off the choices you're making at
18 one thing but your 32 you're a grown
woman yeah you've had over a decade to
make good choices yeah and if you're on
government housing and you've made poor
decisions to get there like that's all
you know you know you can't pay you know
it's it's not all subsidized you do know
that don't you so I I told you I didn't
understand so you're you're kind of
almost going with like a narrative that
is all paid for you you don't know that
you do people that make good financial
decisions end up on this government
housing typically it all depends their
life you don't you don't of course but
there's gonna be